it's really significant it is the second
largest city in ukraine it's very close
to the russian border about 20 miles in
distance and up until this point the
ukrainian military has been able to keep
russian forces out however in the last
couple of hours we heard from the
ukrainian interior ministry they said a
group of special forces russian
special forces
has entered harkief i just got off the
phone with someone in harkev he said
russian forces had entered in two
different directions from the northeast
and northwest in armored columns and sky
news has verified
pictures of russian trucks russian
lorries entering into har keep also
russian troops on the ground i should
also say
that there are unverified pictures on
social media as well of burning russian
vehicles
as well
a tank or an apc an armored personnel
carrier
certainly looks or appears that at least
one of these columns has been stopped
and i think this is one of the problems
that the
the russians have basically the vast
majority of people who live in that city
do not want their soldiers to be there
the person i was speaking to he was in
his basement he was he was taking
shelter but he said look you know this
this is a city with many many ethnic
russians with many russian speakers but
the fact is it has changed the city has
changed over the last 10 15 years people
do not want a russian invasion their
loyalty ultimately is to the ukrainian
government to the ukrainian state and i
think this is going to be a big problem
for the russians they are going to be
able to move
uh special forces into cities like
harkeef then they are going to have to
try and occupy these cities they're
going to have to try and hold them and
that is altogether a different challenge
we found out yesterday here in dinipro
that the vast majority of people just
don't want them they don't support them
they've been rallying together at these
community
forums these civic buildings trying to
contribute whatever they can to the
ukrainian war effort whether that's food
water medicines for internally displaced
people or actually to sign themselves up
to the military i'm talking about men
women a wide range of age groups as well
and
support for ukraine runs very very deep
indeed